this episode brought to you by gray
block pizza 18:11 Pico Boulevard on the
way to the beach in Los Angeles gray
block and get in you know this episode
brought to you by Ridge wallet Ridge
wallet is a special customs type of um
style of wallet a lot of people you know
you ask them if they have a wallet and
they don't even know what you're talking
about
because maybe they don't speak English
but that Ridge wallet it's uh it's just
that cutting edge of wallet tree a lot
of people you know they might have a
wallet in their back pocket but that
Ridge that thing does that's that front
pocket
that's that front pocket item like oh is
that a Ridge in your pocket yes it is
boo-boo yes it is you can go to Ridge
wallet dot-com slash Theo th EO for 10%
off they have some beautiful hitters I
use one at first I wasn't sure about it
and now I'm a hundred percent sure that
I like my Ridge wallets man it's getting
hot out there isn't it you feel that
heat you feel that heat some time you
just got to just get out in the yard and
just just show your nipples to the
sunlight you feel me it's this past
weekend but this guy sounds like he's
from another country and there's an
exchange rate apparently on pronouns on
word you go to G Man G up G up baby I
like that do we all have to G up baby
G up baby who needs a Red Bull G up he
was playing this Stevie starlites
[Music]
and that's that music like you know if
you ever seen that movie um Hannibal
Lecter's and Hannibal Lecter's is about
a man who he gets so hungry he starts
eating people in his neighborhood and
gee I think Gene Hackman who's in at
Gene Hackman and and there's a scene in
it where there's a man in a basement I
think the man was like a milkman or like
a uh something like that and the man is
uh he's stuck in his basement and he's
dancing and he has his his wiener tucked
between his legs you know I'm playing
he's playing that you know he's you know
playing hide the [ __ ] Fox you know
and he has his wiener and his nuts
tucked back between his legs and he's
dancing and this sounds like the kind of
music that that guy's listening to
[Music]
Slithe song
sotto
[Music]
Wow
why must we wait when we're alive it's a
great question man and it's one and
Stevie starlight was on an episode here
a month ago and you know just uh he's a
rare gentleman
you know he's that rare sort of uh that
mixed breed between humanity and nature
you know he's that crossbred you know as
if like a couple rays of sunlight and a
snow bank wearing a gangbang with uh
with a uterus and then they made a baby
and that's that's that Stevie starlight
and that's his music right there and
that song is called come over you can
find it on YouTube
Stevie starlight come over and it's
never too late you know we've talked we
talked about this on here sometimes it's
never too late to make that adjustment
it's never too late to have a change
it's never too late to get out of you
know even the dark parts of us even them
dark hearts it's never too late you know
there's times in my life even when I
think back you know 10 years when I
think about back when I was a child some
of the feelings that I had and
uncertainties and even ignorances that I
had and those are gone now some of them
are gone some of them have changed some
of them have evolved some of the
ignorances have some of them are all
some of those things have have calcified
in a book and I've come to the
conclusion no they're not you know
they're okay I'm not
they weren't ignorant as they were they
were things that I'm sure of you know
some of them have calcified and with
with more facts and more support and you
know it just is never too late there's
never too late for things to adjust and
and and and to take a little bit of
wiggle out of that jiggle you know and
you have things tighten up a little bit
or things evolve or things change you
know you could be in a marriage it's
never too late to change it you could be
alone and it's never too late to change
it you could have two legs and this and
you could get [ __ ] hit by a train bra
while you're doing a karate kick and you
could lose one of your legs say you do a
karate kick out across some railroad
tracks and bam you know I'm saying you
didn't know
and now you're that dude you know I'm
saying you that [ __ ] that dude
everybody calls flamingo but that's okay
it's never too late for anything to
happen it's never too late
good to be here man I just got back from
Bakersfield you know I just rolled in a
couple hours ago and they call it baked
Oh I didn't know that to like it's good
out here in baked oh yeah it's just
funny how like like everything starts to
get shortened you know everything starts
to hear just like um it's not
hypothesized but I guess it's everything
starts to get like like instead of
Chicago it's like cago you know we're
out here in cargo you know we're out
here in a instead of Minnesota mini or
Minneapolis mini you know we're out here
in Beirut we're out here in route you
know we're out here instead of Nigeria
it's Niger or out here in giryu you know
we're instead of out here in Toledo
right here in Lido you know where
instead of I have rabies I got raves you
know I don't think anybody says raves
but that's that's something that I was
just making up I hope you guys having a
good day it is uh it's it's it's
summertime and it's summertime it's hot
out there and had a great time on
Bakersfield so many people came out and
we just lived it up man they had some
some lady she's like I spend so much
time in my kitchen I got a whole tattoo
of my kitchen on my back and then she
showed me her back and it was all you
could see was like a little kitchenette
you could see like part of a counter
it's toaster coffeepot and then she
points over her shoulder and had a
broken window this tattoo dude crazy
artwork she goes yeah that's uh
yo my ex-husband broke that window out
with a broom handle when he was angry at
me and I'm like Jesus this lady's just
carrying that around is carrying that
long day around she'd had a long day I'm
sure in that kitchen that day and she's
carrying her around on her back
you know she's carrying that around on
her back what else man had some nice
people out Madame Mehta you know this
fella named Tyler came out cool cat this
young dude that like playing soccer came
out
um who else man they had this uh blonde
haired lady says she's a accountant or
something she doesn't want to be an
accountant or no she's scientists or
something you know I said well we need
scientists we got we need everything so
just be something you know just be
something but it's it's uh it's been a
crazy week I got to tell you guys this
you a shot of me
you're not even gonna believe this and
I'm almost kind of like I'm gonna find
Barris to say it I guess I'm just like
insecure about it I I was in a music
video you know like a music video you
see on the internet and they used to
have it on MTV but now it's just on um
it's on YouTube and this music is by bad
baby and you know our beehad baby I
think be hot baby is uh she is that you
know cashed me outside and I'm saying
catch me outside you know it's like
before venmo they had cashed me outside
and and she was on dr. Phil you know
it's like dr. Phil's stepdaughter or
something and she got angry at dr. Phil
and they were fighting and and she was
impersonating you know kind of more of
an urban girl type of vibe anyhow I got
to work with bad baby and she's got a
rap album out now and she has a there's
a video coming out she has a song called
trust me so let me tell you what
happened for me so a friend of mine is a
director of the video and he just did
her last video and it's called Gucci
flip-flops and we'll put the links to
them below you can check it out and mine
is the one I mean though when I'm in
isn't out yet and so I get a I get a
text from the director he's like hey
would you be interested in doing this
here's the link of the last one I sent
so watch the last one I'm like wow you
know this thing has you know it's got 50
something million views it's it's
cool-looking it's really artistic it's
funny it's fun I'm like yeah I'll do
that you know I'll definitely I'll
definitely try this thing out so oh oh
but first I read the script right and in
the script I play a pervert I play a
pervert
and if you don't know what a perverted
as a pervert is say your masturbator so
you like to masturbate right but say you
don't but say you now suddenly you take
your show on the road
that's a pervert because a masturbator
is somebody masturbates at their house
you know a lot of you know could be a
man or a woman some men like to spray
out and ladies like to kind of more
spray in and and a master a masturbator
is somebody that does that you know
sprays out or in but a pervert as
somebody that's like ah but you do that
indoors that's somebody who sprays out
or in but also indoors they do it inside
of a domicile in an igloo under a hat
you know some people if they're you know
if your trap if you're stuck outdoors
and you want to jerk off some people
back in the day they would dig a hole
and get down in just get under all the
dirt put all the dirt back on top of
them and then jerk off down in the dirt
you know and that's old school that's
[ __ ] that's some nineteen hundred
[ __ ] you know that's nineteen hundred
style but this uh but a perverted
somebody that instead of doing it behind
closed doors they go out and do it out
in the bout or they do it at a party or
they do it at a you know Kinson era you
know somebody blows out the candles on
there in the distance
you know warming up one more frickin one
more candy there in the distance you
know starting up a little cake of their
own you know and that's a pervert and so
anyway the thing on there it's like you
have to play a pervert and I'm like and
look I'm not a pervert man I'm not a
pedophile I haven't didn't ever done
anything like that and I've babysat
overnight I've babysat overnight with my
nieces and nephews countless times and I
feel eternally grateful and thankful
that I I don't have that that infection
that disease because that's that that's
a that's a troubling disease you know
and we look at those people that have
those types of things and we say man you
know it's it's so unfortunate for their
victims and it is
it's also nobody's starting their life
out choosing to be that way you know I'm
saying choosing to wear a a backpack
made out of Satan you know choosing a
run around with the dark arts just
flowing so strong inside of their veins
that they you know they almost would cut
their wrists just to relieve themselves
of the dark desires that they have and
and so anyway I got that dude next thing
you know I'm reading the script I'm like
damn there's a creepy guy in here and
then I get to the end I'm like oh
there's only really two people in it but
Baja baby and and the creepy guy I'm
like [ __ ] dude I'm the creepy guy I'm
the pervert so next thing you know the
director text me is like well look man
uh David Spade recommended you and I'm
like oh wow that's crazy because first
of all David Spade is one of my favorite
entertainers of all time I mean you know
the fact I mean we have Chris Farley his
up a painting of Chris Farley up here in
our studio and the fact that he got to
work with him black sheep Tommy Boy
you know what's the the movie uh I think
he was in sin of a woman I think or
something I don't know but or he just
gets a lot of us yeah you know but um
but I love David Spade Oh Joe Dirt and
people you know and I thought Joe Dirt a
lot of people know this I thought it was
a documentary when I first saw it and I
remember when I finally got to interview
David Spade he came on allegedly which
uh was a podcast that I've done with
Matthew Cole Weiss for a while and he
came on Oh allegedly and he's like and
and I was like hey did a lot of orphans
like reach out to you and Joe Dirt came
out and he's like what are you talking
about and I was like whoa and I
explained to him you know and he's like
dude that's not a [ __ ] documentary
he's like you're an idiot and I was like
oh that's awesome and you know David
Spade he's called me an idiot and made
me feel good but anyhow so next thing
you know the director is like well why
don't you get in touch with David Spade
and I'm like I don't know
David's phase number you know I'm saying
you know I'm not just walking around
with people like David Spade's number or
people like you know who else Kris
Kringle frickin um Rain Man anybody else
dude
Wolverine who the [ __ ] does this guy
think I am you know Katy Perry I don't
have just ultimate numbers in my phone
so he sends me David Spade's number and
like oh wow what do I do with David
Spade's number so I'm like just like I'm
like I don't really call and I know
David Spade through we have a mutual
friend Adam egit who book who's the
Booker at The Comedy Store and I know
him through just seeing him in circles
and we chat sometimes a little bit and
he's yeah I would consider us buddies
but I wouldn't say that we're really
friends yet you know because we just
haven't I don't know him well enough and
I you know it's that weird thing or like
I don't want to it like I don't feel
like a fanboy at around him or anything
but I am a fan of his work so it's you
know it's it's not a it's not
uncomfortable but it's it's um you know
there's an admiration there that
sometimes I get excited about maybe I
can't hide and he might be like man uh
there's a fun conversation but your
cheeks are all flushed or your eyes are
flickering while we're talking you know
or you're erect like what's going on
buddy so you know sometime I can't hide
my you know just genuine excitement that
God just sends out just vibing out
through my through my you know my
eyelids or through my even my crotch
sometimes if I'm you know keyed up or
excited so next thing you know I have
David Spade's number and I call it goes
to voicemail and then I get a call back
and this is um and so I'm like what the
hell how do I do I stand up do I sit
down and I'm saying to a lay down how do
I answer the phone David Spade calls so
um you know I'm just trying to like I go
outside I was inside of a loud place and
I'm like I don't want him to think that
I you know hang out in loud places you
know like I don't know what the [ __ ] I
was thinking dude and then I was like oh
dude I don't feel like I'm very tall
because I always have this thing in my
head like I don't feel like um because I
am six feet tall even though some people
will say I'm not
and if you look at like old you know
older if use like an old [ __ ] ruler
from a long time ago where they didn't
really put that full inch in there then
yeah
then I definitely make it but if you use
kind of these newer rulers where things
are a lot more can you know certain I
don't get there and I think I get there
and some people say I don't but I think
I come in right at six feet you know and
strong that looking you know I'm so if
you know I'm right there five eleven and
seven eight stood and if the wind blows
up or they don't [ __ ] kind of pick me
up just enough to get me at that six
foot but I always have these
insecurities you know how the
insecurities of having that you know I
have a limited neck my neck doesn't go
very far even we've talked about that on
here and I talk about it a lot you know
I'm saying I can't really look around
that much so after you look forward or I
have to turn around and then also look
forward which is behind me at that point
cuz I turned around and so next thing
you know man iced so I stand on a bench
there's a bench right there so I'm like
well [ __ ] I want to sound tall when I
talked to David Spade on the phone even
though re no he already knows how tall I
am right
so next II know I'm on the phone and
he's like he starts telling about the
video and I said well look I just you
know I'm a little nervous I don't wanna
be seen as like a pervert you know I
don't want to be seen as a a PDF file
and so he's like nah man he's like this
is a chance for you to like act you know
like a you you you get to be funny a lot
but you get to be you know creepy and
dark and I'm like well you know I have a
I said I've struggled over my life with
you know masturbation and stuff like
that and he's like what the [ __ ] you
talkin about I was like I don't know
and so then we kind of thankfully got
out of that topic for a second but I was
trying to tell him that I've been into
some dark arts or anything you know you
know I've had some issues and addiction
issues and stuff but um he's just like
look this is a chance for you to play a
creeper you can be a creeper and that's
it so next thing you know I text the
director and I said I'm in and two days
later I'm on I'm on set with bad bad
baby look
I thought it was beehad baby and then I
thought I was like well her fan base has
to be called be Haj jihad right but it
is it is behead bad when I first taught
us like if she has sheep on her yeah
Danielle bra goalie that be had baby you
know cache me outside
so anyway next thing on one set and boom
there I am and I'm on it's like and dude
it to a real music video there's like
smoke and there are there's like a table
in the distance with everybody eating
orange slices and like fancy oranges
like oranges from [ __ ] Sweden or
Portland and everybody's you know they
have all kind of cashews and and they
have you know people they have some
dudes walking on with radios and [ __ ]
weren't doing [ __ ] but just you know
carrying around electronics basically
and it was in the next you know I'm in
this dude I'm playing I'm playing a
pervert and I'm playing a pervert and
and we did we did the whole video and
and we did a night shoot and it was in
it was wild and then I came back two
days later we did some pick-me-ups so
it's just gonna be something you're
gonna be able to it was the craziest
thing like you would never think I would
be in that and and then there I was man
but the crazy party is here's one of the
weirdest things so you know a couple of
my friends knew about it and I don't
even know if I'm supposed to tell
anybody about it but you know what I'm
saying this is this is what we do on
here we just say what what's going on
and so and my buddies are texting me and
they're like hey man that chick is so
hot bro set me up
and what do what are you talking I'm
playing a pervert bro because of God
like you because of guys like you I'm
here and this is the role of men so it
was just intense man our buddies like
set me up with her like you must set you
up with a child but there's a lot that's
called sex trafficking it's called sex
trafficking
man so it's just you know it's just wild
but then also you know she gets its
while how we sexualized I don't want to
say that we sexualized children but
there's the industry like you know
you'll put a girl and have her look
sexual you know if they're developed
you'll have them look sexual and I just
start to wonder like I guess there's if
somebody's a you know is really a
pervert then they're just they can't
they don't know when to say okay that's
that is a child or that's a kid or
that's legally not okay and then you
know and then it is okay you know
because that starting line is 18 so
that's the starting line but uh but yeah
I guess that's the difference if some
people can't shut down that part of
their brain where they want to you know
join a you know they want to you know
coach children's softball or whatever or
that kind of stuff anyway I don't know
why I got in all that but you can see me
in a bad baby music video coming out and
look I was so nervous like there's one
part where I'm like because she catches
me and I'm like pin down on this it like
Dexter style deal on my [ __ ] you know
and uh and I'm Mike and I even said to
the director I was like dude I just want
to like I'm okay with I said just tell
me this tell me if I look like somebody
who can't act trying to act that's what
I do not want to look like that he's
like nah man you did a good job and it
was but it was pretty crazy man it was
just crazy it was crazy to be in there
and uh and people are like well what's
Danielle bergoglio like what's behind
baby like and I said well she's the cash
me outside girl you know she all she
know and that's who she is
and she's also a kid she's nice she's uh
she's a ninth grader so when you talk to
her it's like talking to somebody in the
ninth grade you know but she definitely
had a lot of swagger she was definitely
fun she was fun to be around she had a
good sense of humor I thought like the
second time we did pickup shots which
was last night or two nights ago she
made it like it was it was easy to joke
around and stuff
I mean if anything what I realized about
myself was that definitely because I
look I haven't been around a
fifteen-year I don't hang out around any
people this age and so good hey first of
all you know and it was just you know I
realized like oh yeah these these kids
this is another generation they live in
a world that I do not know about and I
am thankful that I don't know about it
and I'm thankful that I'm just here
playing a pervert or PDF file today just
as an actor and not suffering with that
in my real life and I'm grateful for
that man because I remember being in
college and I was in college and I was
at Louisiana State University and I'm a
we had a professor and he came into
class one day it was like statistics or
something like that or something like
that and he comes in and he goes um
statistically speaking this he's like
there's 800 people in here so it was
first year because there's 800 800 800
students in here statistically speaking
you know 170 of you guys will get
divorced statistically speaking you know
for you guys will be in a lawsuit
because you you know burns your arm at a
Pizza Hut or something and then
statistically speaking to you guys will
be convicted of pedophile pedophilia or
something and a second I heard that I
remember to stand and up dude in the
middle of that class and just saying not
it that's what I said I said not it and
I made that line and the stand right in
the sand I made the line in the sand
right then for myself that I wasn't
gonna sit around and let that rule that
wall that of that roulette ball a life
just bouncing laying wherever it wanted
to on me that I was gonna stand up and
say not it today professor I'm not being
a damn pervert from my life anyhow so
that's so I'm gonna be in a I'm gonna be
in a music video and that's gonna be it
I guess
I'm a video vixen they call them those
you know those girls that are popping
their asses because sometimes you see
these girls I don't if you've seen this
on the internet but the internet it's
like your computer but when you're not
really doing any work you're just
[ __ ] losing your mind and getting
angry and looking at it it's basically
kind of tits but they have these things
called video vixens and they just also
have these big asses and the asses don't
even look like asses anymore
I'm surprised some way they look like
big tits you know big you know big butt
tits and I'm surprised that some women
don't get nipples installed on their
asses think about it cuz then you got
them big back titties bro you got them
rear tops you've got them rear tops you
know now if you motorboat those dude you
might you know I'm saying you might want
to brush your teeth after but but but
they treat the way they shake them they
have these rap videos rappers you know
uh they're kind of like you know kind of
darker musicians kind of and the way
they shake the UM you know we're like I
don't wanna say chocolate in musicians
but it's kind of at least I mean I an
Eminem and I guess but he doesn't even
really get into it anymore but you know
I'm saying they have but they have these
these asses that just shake and it
almost looks like people have Tourette's
and their ass cheeks but I think the
next thing is and I'm gonna predict this
a future prediction that you're going to
start to see you're gonna start to see
nipples get installed on people's butt
cheeks so they can have that quad that
can be you know then quad tots bra
somebody you know just titties in the
front and you know titties in the back
that heinie then freakin uh then big
hiney bags you know them big hiney bags
so we'll see man we'll see but but yeah
they had a but but they you know I'm
gonna be a video vixen but without the
without the breasts and without them
excitement really I guess I mean it's
supposed to be kind of a dark video it's
kind of scary it has a deck
but anyhow you'll be able to check that
out soon thank you guys for joining us
so this path this past weekend man we
got some great episodes coming up for
you guys soon in studio who dr. Drew
Whitney Cummings
who else others a couple others some
real good ones I don't want to tell you
yet Oh Coco Diaz but there's some
special guests I don't even want to
announce just yet
but we always ask on here who's
listening to this past weekend so let's
let's take a call that came in here we
go what's up Bo this is Steph from
Thibodaux Louisiana out what's up Seth
from Thibodaux Louisiana and I used to
know a boy in my mitt and my arm in my
middle school his family from Thibodeau
and you're never gonna believe this his
name was Larry [ __ ] and PU SSI and he
did I he had he had um no shoulders
really and I don't know how that what
this is called I don't think it's like a
disease or something it's just he was
like a premature baby I'm talking about
Larry puss it was the premature as baby
ever and he was I mean dude I'm
surprised if he wasn't born in about
four months you know and it did probably
was easy to birth him he just came right
out of me no shoulders on him so it was
just like chin in new spine and just on
his arms kind of just kind of sprouted
off of the edge of his rib cage it just
kind of like a downward he's only built
like a Christmas tree a little bit and
uh and he had he was allergic to
everything man he was allergic to
everything he had to have his um he had
a cousin or something he was kind of fat
or a little bit and no offense if
anybody's putting on weight but this kid
this was a kid and I don't even think
that kid listens to this and he was
fatter so you know we've all got
something but he was fatter and he had
to carry an umbrella over Larry all the
time because Larry couldn't get the
sunlight he couldn't get too much wind
he always always sneeze and I don't you
ever seen anybody know shoulder sneeze
new you think they're gonna die whenever
time it happens I mean I remember
watching him sneeze one time it knocked
him off his feet because when you you
don't have shoulders you can't balance
and your shirt he had to tie his shirt
up around the top or he put like you
know he'd have a shirt on but he'd have
it like you know tied up back behind his
um in his back you know because there's
nothing to hold your shirt I mean you're
just
but yeah boy freaking Larry puts it from
Thibodaux Louisiana but anyhow I know
that's not you and I appreciate you
callin let's hear more Seth I'm your
away man
I just really wanted to call and let you
know I appreciate you man you know I got
a girl I got two stepkids I got a baby
on the way I work at a machine shop I
work 12 13 hours a day 6 days a week and
you know your podcast really helps me
get through some of those days man I
just want to call and let you know that
dude I appreciate that man Louisiana
pride right there I appreciate you
calling Seth and and I'm sure that you
your your baby on the way and your wife
and in your step I think you said you
have a stepdaughter stepchild I'm sure
that they appreciate you man you know
even though they might not always you
know they did admit they may always
express it I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about but but you know I'm
saying you taking care of your into the
deal and there's something very
admirable about that you know and I hope
you had a nice Father's Day and and
you'll have that that first Father's Day
with your new baby next year that's
exciting dude I used to work at a
machine shop over there off of uh across
the river over in in Metairie where the
[ __ ] was that she had over in Algiers
and I was out there and I was they had
these piping pipes and like clevis these
clamps and clevis hangers and all of
this [ __ ] dude and I don't know a lot of
it because I got fired but uh but my job
was to put glue on these pipes and put
this rubber on them so um so so those
two these clamps you could put a pipe in
a clamp because you can't just put metal
on metal you got to put a thing a rubber
in there to protect it so I'd be out in
the Sun putting glue on and whenever the
song dancy little stranger show me where
you been Oh
I just wanna fly when that song would
come on all the people in the machine
shop would shut down they quit they quit
doing what they were doing quit the
welding and me and the other glue boys
we had a couple of glue boys out there
we would uh we'd be out there in the Sun
they make us dance during that song
so we had to dance for these uh older
men which i think is definitely a little
weird because i was think i was only 16
but it wasn't there wasn't anything
homoerotic about it or anything patty a
Phil pedia philic it was just natural it
was just people having fun like kind of
um it was something you would see in a
fraternity like the older guys make the
younger guys do something you know it's
like a little bit of hazing but one day
dude we were a little bit hungover we're
out there with this you know dancing
with these glue brushes and we started
painting each other with glue and you
think that's fun don't you think it's
fun to paint your buddies with glue out
in the hot Sun dude until that [ __ ]
starts to eat you up and that just
starts to really really eat you up and
my buddy his bellybutton got a bunch of
glue in it and man he had an infection
for probably 1,100 days so but thanks
for calling Seth and that's who listens
to this podcast who else listens hey
Tony from Buffalo New York I'm a prison
guard hey Tony prison guard dude so you
definitely have Doug in some people's
[ __ ] for drugs bro and I respect
that people don't respect the stuff you
guys do a lot of times I used to be
friends with JP lo ceman who played for
the Buffalo Bills a while back and and I
got to go up there and watch a game one
time at um Ralph Waldo Ralph Waldo
Emerson Stadium I think it is and we had
a good time onward Tony's wanted to say
after a miserable you know just
depressing we can't work is like nothing
better than coming home and listening to
the podcast lift me up get me out of
that swamp
you know most of got okay I just wanted
to say growing up I didn't have a lot of
friends and I looked at it as like I
just had different levels than enemies
you know and I'm glad you can make me
laugh make me feel alive and I
appreciate you man I appreciate you Tony
thank you for that dude and thank you
for your service you know I'm so they
come down so hard on all these prison
workers and
prison wardens and you know prisons are
the worst and this and that and they
never taken account that people worked
in there and people do their jobs and
there's people up there you know we're
keeping these you know some some dark
artists the dark is stuff you know I'm
talking to Pablo Picasso's of primordial
paint you know and primordial tonight
though not the right word but I'm
talking about people that are slithering
now I can tuck them under Gryffindor
daddy's talking about real some real
Slytherin soldiers men the dark artists
and you you're and you're keeping them
up in they're caged up and that's
appreciated but then I want to listen to
this line that you said one more time
and there's nothing better than coming
home listening to the podcast lift me up
get me out of that swamp
you know once it's cut okay I just
wanted to say growing up I didn't have a
lot of friends and I looked at it as
like I just had different levels than
enemies you know wow that's that's
interesting man it's interesting to hear
that I didn't have friends you know I
just had different levels of enemies
because that really put that a man I'd
so crazy you say that because I could
feel that at certain points in my life
you not gonna feel me thinking man if I
you know like when you feel alone this
is interesting when you feel alone or
for me this is interesting I'm not
preaching at you I'm just I'm listening
to you Tony and I'm thinking them based
on some stuff you said and when you're
when you feel alone you then our I then
when I feel alone and a in you to Tony
it sounds like we then look at other
people as enemies man I've really
resonates with me because I feel like I
did that a lot in my life you know and
that's when you're alone you feed that's
when you have no body and you don't have
an you kidding you that you feel like
nobody has you that's the thing
that's the thing about being alone it's
not that you feel like you don't have
anybody it's like you feel like nobody
has you and man and I know when
especially when we're young that's so we
can't even put it into words but we can
feel that and I could remember a lot as
a child feeling that way you know just
feeling like
but he has me nobody has nobody has me
and I really remember feeling like that
and then I look at everybody else has
the enemy you know I don't have friends
I got different levels of enemies the
world hates me this ended with there's
some there's this there's a power out
there greater than at all in it or the
greater power whatever it is after this
world hates me and so therefore every
person in it must there are different
levels of enemies you know when you grew
up in an environment where your back is
against the wall or or you or you go
through a time in your life when your
back is against the wall man that's so
you're so scared you know to be honest
you know I think I was so scared and all
I don't know how about it know how to
care about anybody you know nobody
taught me how to care but the one thing
I did know was uh how to how to make
sure I knew that that person was in I
would that oh they're an enemy they may
be the best they may be my closest enemy
and those you know but but they're out
to get me or they don't believe in me or
they don't want me or I'm not good
enough for them those are the things
that were I just attached to everybody
even people that love me other my
closest enemy because somewhere in my
head I just didn't have that trust
somewhere in my heart I didn't that
trust for others that would let me
really you know embrace the care that
they probably wanted to give me a lot of
times you know and a lot of that comes
from just fear you know when you grow up
scared or you go through times and
you're scared man that's a powerful
statement though Tony I appreciate you
saying that that you know I'd never
thought of I didn't have any friends I
just had I want to hear that one more
time man sorry I'm super forgetful lift
me up get me out of that funk
you know once it's cut okay I just
wanted to say growing up I didn't have a
lot of friends and I looked at it as
like I just had different levels of
enemies you know and I'm glad you can
make me laugh me
you bet man I'm glad you can make me
think dude you know you set up you know
you send this message in today you just
call it and hit the hotline and you made
me think and you made me think about
that I didn't have cuz I couldn't have
if I if I said you were my friend and
that was a weakness somehow it was a
weakness for me cuz all I knew how to be
all I knew how I didn't know how to love
I just knew how to defend myself against
people against I didn't know how to love
against people who probably wanted to
care about me
oh no maybe that's all it is is I didn't
know how to love I just knew how to
defend myself like it's almost like that
was the only emotion that I had was how
to defend myself and by pointing people
out his enemies are different levels of
enemies it was just an easy organized
way to defend myself immediately thank
you for calling turnout I mean to do
well into that too much but I'm trying
to think at the same time and trying to
feel you know sometimes I don't like to
think I like to try and see what my
feelings are telling me because I for me
my brain is - it's so infected these
days so influence there's so much going
on that it's almost I really have to try
and get into my feelings and surf those
a little bit almost like I'm like if you
see a old man on the beach sometime you
see an old man on the beach you know and
his wife is deceased or she's up in the
room and she's [ __ ] probably you know
eating edibles and [ __ ] zone and out
on you know and watching 60 minutes
backwards or something and you know just
doing some wild you know low-key crazy
senior citizen style [ __ ] but the man is
out on the beach and he's looking for
treasure
and he's out there really all he's
trying to find is some other [ __ ] in
the sand you know what I'm saying I'm
he's trying to find a portal he's trying
to find a portal that I get him away
from his wife but you see that man he's
out there looking he's waiting for that
beep and that's how I am sometimes when
it comes to like my feelings it's like I
have to kind of talk until I feel like
something like pings in me and then when
something pings I mean like oh that's
there's a watch and the sand right there
there's a you know a doubloon or there's
a you know there's a rusty earring or
something or a piece of a railroad tie
or something like that there's some
under my sand there and that's and I
have to wait until I get that ping and
then I have to try and you know just sir
keep moving or keep moving the the metal
detector over that until I detect a
little bit more of my feelings and try
to figure him out but thank you for that
call Tony we had some follow-up calls
about last week's titties we had the
gentleman with the tip two weeks ago Jay
I believe his name was Joey
Teddy Joey I think and I'm not
I'm not calling you titty Joey I know
that's not your name and I'm not making
fun of you I'm just trying to surmise it
or summarize it so we can get through it
quicker but but we'll have a few more
responses to that and I also want to
tell you that I'm going to China so you
know me and Joe Rogan on his podcast
we're talking about what's the best hat
to masturbate in and I you know he we
had some different types of hats we went
back and forth and we eventually ended
up at a Chinese type hat because that
you know if you squat all the way down
then you basically you're in a small
house do you know I'm saying it's
basically your standard [ __ ] a little
Howard Johnson almost and so I'll be in
in China I'll be in Shanghai and you'll
be able to come out and see some shows
there and those dates are July 12th 13th
and 14th I'll be at the Swiss Grand
Hotel in a giant shape chime in and then
I'll be at cages sports bar in Shanghai
on the 13th and one more show on the
14th in Shanghai as well
you can go to Theo von comm slash tour
and find out other cities I'm coming to
this Tuesday June 26 at 8:00 p.m. I'll
be at the Hollywood improv I'm running
my pretty much like an hour I'll be
doing about it now I'm gonna be there
with some surprise guests I'm not
telling you who yet then I'm being
Wyoming Illinois Oxnard California China
Raleigh North Carolina Minneapolis
Chicago Nashville Toronto Appleton
Buffalo and Salt Lake City all those are
available at theof on calm slash tour t
oh you are alright we have some cool
calls that came in let's get into a
couple of these men you know we do on
here I'm you can hit the hotline
whenever if you have a question a
concern a feeling of fear anything you
know this is this is a joint effort that
we do here and that number is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
every month we give out a prize prize
pack to somebody who has the best or
worst weekend you just have to call and
share with us don't share any freaking
boring weekends it has to be great or
bad so here are two of those homeward
hey Phil boy cooter over here and Idaho
Wow cooter that's crazy dude and I was
just telling you about Larry [ __ ] what
what and you're sayin now people are
being like oh god don't exist
God don't exist so then I was talking
about LP and then cooter calls Kim yeah
so I'm calling to your little uh the
best weekend worst weekend
deal Saturday was my birthday Sunday was
Father's Day so I am just this a lady in
my life you know I've known her for
about eight years we've been dating now
for six months on Sunday on Father's Day
was our six-month deal
happy anniversary min or half
anniversary homeward Saturday we'll wake
up she makes me breakfast open some
presents she got me like almost a whole
damn packer stores the whole [ __ ]
store oh wow there there's nothing
better than Amanda's dressed head-to-toe
in in green and gold you know I'm saying
when you see that you see that man like
a you see a man just just doused up in
in in Green Bay Packers green and gold
you look at that man you say yeah dang
that guy is that guy has a pervert more
Green Bay Packer fan she got me bunch of
shirts hat cooler she got me a Davante
Adams earthy oh dude so she's definitely
making sure that no other chicks are
gonna hit on you with these with all of
this [ __ ] let's hear more if anything a
couple dudes might molester for that uh
for that cooler more cooter with a
cooler cam and uh then we went golfing
you know send their golfing you got you
got you just get ready Platt get the
ball up there and you sit there you go
out get in there and we came home and
you know had dinner and whatnot and had
friends come over and had my kid and and
whatnot for a Father's Day and then the
icing on the whole cake
this woman went out bought herself a
Packers shirt and ended up having sex
with me in the Packer shirt and then
yell out at the very end
don't pack go wow she yelled out go pack
go at the end of the whole thing man
that is you know what I'll say this is
an old-fashioned men's weekend and it's
a good one when that's a good one you
know what the coolest thing about that
is is that she just cared she cared that
much when she doused you up and all that
green and gold
she's like nobody's coming after him you
know what I'm saying
unless it's like an iris jaundice woman
you know I'm saying on st. Patrick's Day
unless it's a jaundiced lady on st.
Patrick's Day nobody's gonna come after
this green and gold creature that I'm
putting together and Neal had some
friends come over and then she sent the
friends home that was just a ruse and
then she put on a special shirt she put
on a shirt that represented a bunch of
men playing sweaty sports out there and
you guys did it and they yelled go pack
go at the end and you know what I say
take that [ __ ] Minnesota Vikings
there you go that's beautiful man thank
you for sharing about that weekend I'm
glad I'm glad you get a nice time I
sound like it sound like you you know
some dreams kind of you know came
fulfilled right there for you and that
you guys might have a bright future dude
because if so if it's just those little
things that can make you happy somebody
expressing that love and y'all get a
little bit of sex out there some you
know nighttime sex and doing sex with
each other
Cameron as beautiful okay let's take a
second call right here here we go hey
Nick thank you for calling on in this
past weekend homeward Florida dude do
you have Florida on business what you
doin do drug mewling you know Florida on
business huh
what you doing boy slinging ivory
huh you smuggling [ __ ] baby bones
what are you doing down that Florida on
business my him while I was there little
husky girl walked over to me as she
liked my shirt
oh yeah that's that husky line
right there I like that shirt more about
it let's watch sure what a creative
that's a creative line there let's swap
shirts because of at least one a all is
gonna somebody's gonna take their shirt
off and then somebody might not but then
at least one of you already have your
shirt off so that's a start you know
that's a start for love right there and
then that's what a great idea it's kind
of fun it's creative you know you could
play music while you're doing it and the
last person to get the shirt on loses or
something like musical shirts let's hear
more let's walk down to the water walk
down to the water
posture finger of my mouth who that
finger in the mouth huh
that's that dummy check boy that's a
dummy chick what do I know one of those
juicy strawberry edible oh she put that
candy in you she put that candy in your
face boy she's treating me like a drug
mule but up front you know cuz a lot of
thing that's a [ __ ] dope suppository
some people when I was young used to put
dope in yes you know if you wanted to do
drugs fast but you were busier to go to
work or you had to babysit or you know
you know run a marathon or whatever you
put a little drugs and you ass and now
people are putting drugs straight into
their mouths or eating at all let's hear
more had a good time that's my weekend
jjang jjang gang gang dude you out there
meeting some husky girls out there you
get out there getting in that I did a
rod boy a couple of Huskies a little bit
of shirt swapping hiding candies in each
other's mouths dummy checking each
other's tongues you know I'm saying
those up front suppositories and bam you
guys are finding love and I love that
thank you for calling in those are two
great submissions for all the weekend
and what's going on and how your weekend
was if it was the best or the worst you
can submit yours nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three okay we had a
couple calls that came in in response
again to that man titties people called
in about the man titties a few more
responses and some follow-up let's get
into it see
Oh Kevin from New Jersey thank you for
calling Kevin from Jersey boy calling
about the guy that caught up with the
man titties
oh yeah that's that baby that's that
beautiful bad-boy man that's tits past
weekend more and then the other guy
calls up and tells them it's okay
or that nobody's better than him or
anyone's better than and it's just okay
and just accept it it's not okay if
you're a man you're not supposed to have
titties it's about discipline and if
he's okay with it that's fine nobody's
better than him but what the [ __ ] man
don't say yeah it's okay to have tits
and celebrate being fat you're [ __ ]
fat you got tits look in the mirror
there's probably other parts of your
body that are [ __ ] up too well some
people might have fat did you know cuz I
had a man dick even when I was a child I
remember six years old people will come
around to see my dick you know and it
wasn't like I was a
and they weren't pedophiles they were
just like wow that then wow that kids
really carting around some [ __ ] you know
but I mean you said this that it's not
disciplined but how disciplined is it
this way look I mean how discipline is
it to have man breasts okay
then to not lose your [ __ ] every time
somebody says something about it that I
mean to me that's discipline you know I
mean there's a couple things disciplines
you can have yeah if he's overweight and
he's not you know he's not taking care
of his weight then or his weight is you
know some people's weight is all
different you know I'm saying people
coming all types of weights you know I
knew a man he was like 600 pounds didn't
you couldn't even see his head or
anything his shoulders came up over his
head and so if you had to pull back some
of his front and it hear him if he said
something you had to pull down his you
know you had to pull part of his body
down and listen for you know some clues
from him but if you know so if he's yeah
if unit but here's the thing if you if
you're not handling your weight in a way
that keeps you fit and you have these
breasts you know you've got these man's
you know these you got these chesticles
then then what about this though that's
one thing you didn't handle the
discipline there are you or we're unable
to but then if people are ripping you up
people are making fun of you
but you don't let that get to you you
stay that course you know where you're
at now that's another discipline now we
talking in you know you're that [ __ ]
titties samurai at that point cuz you're
able to keep that focus bro you able to
keep that focus and know that the bigger
picture and know that you were headed in
a different direction and it doesn't
matter what these other people say so
there's other kind there's other types
of discipline so we're not - also
telling the minutes okay you know but if
he's hurting from it then yeah I'm gonna
tell him it's okay if somebody's hurting
from it because you can look just one
thing like to be in a mode where it's
like I'm gonna be healthy and I'm gonna
get myself healthy right but then if
you're pay if you're not if you're not
there yet you're still at the point
where you're kind of hurting from it and
that's a different space you can't tell
somebody who's really hurting you can't
tell them hey you need to [ __ ] get in
shape you have to tell them first you
have to first try and be there for them
where they're hurting
get them to a level where they're not
hurting and then I think you can try to
get you know work on more the actual
physical aspect of it I think anyway
I don't know now at the same time dude I
respect the tough-love angle
you know I respect it like you know we
can't tell everybody like oh you can't
say oh everything you know everybody you
know you don't want to take carries if
you don't do this but I think also that
this man and I'm not knocking you down
bro look I respect you got that Jersey
pride you know I'm saying you guys have
done a lot of [ __ ] out in Jersey dude
that's cattle country bro I was raised
on milk dude I remember actually we're
talking about the Green Bay Packers a
minute ago we used to go out there any
mushrooms out there Brett Favre is from
kiln Mississippi when I was young we
would go out there we drive out there
and we would put on Green Bay Packer
jerseys and we'd run around out in the
fields and [ __ ] eat mushrooms and get
by the cows and get the dairy cows and
[ __ ] spray hot milk in each other's
[ __ ] faces brah and that's the time
you want to talk you want to see the
Lord you want to [ __ ] feel Jesus walk
up and down the bridge of your nose brah
you know I'm saying you want to feel you
want to feel bootiful
and tickle your neck nuts that's your
Adam's apple that I mean look then you
get out there spray hot milk on each
other in the home of Brett Favre while
you got on a Brett Favre Jersey news out
there on mushrooms you know while you
out there on on Poseidon's favorite
vegetables you out there on them on them
boomers you hopped up on boomers and
next thing you know you spraying warm
milk on each other go pack go but but
yeah so sometimes it's like yes I don't
you got to do the tough love but
sometimes you got to get somebody in a
place first where you could get them the
tough love but let's hear the rest of
your call and I do appreciate your call
let's hear or more and I called before
but that's like you said just how we do
it in Jersey we keep it real it's true
you guys doing look I'm glad you guys
I'm glad I'm glad we have this element
in the world because we need it look out
here nobody keeps me out here everybody
man look it's like say a baby's born
premature they want to have everything
in the world suddenly be premature they
want to make everybody around the baby
premature no we got to think about the
common good you know we have to think
about the common good that's the thing
what's the bet if what's the movie can
make right now let's say and be the best
for everybody you know we got to think
about the common good let's hear more
and that's it man
no man titties it what's better to have
man titties or no man titties what's
better 99.9 percent of people say no
titties for the homeboy that called and
said it's okay to have to slow it
nobody's better yeah if you ain't got it
you're better anyway love you man later
on love you brah appreciate the call and
look I respect that point of view you
got to have that tough thing sometimes
you know but I do think in this guy's
condition I don't think it's that he
wasn't taking care of his up our trying
to I think that he has something like a
um like a not a deformity you know but
like um we had this boy in my class he
was in a fire this boy Sherman and he
also had he had those [ __ ]
he had those just he had like the and it
looked like um he had real big eyelids
you know look like nut sacks kind of
hanging over his eyes and and so you
know that's not the same thing as saying
hey you got fat eyelids that's different
when he had extra skin up there he had
like God put like little bits of nutsack
like and where his eyelids were but
let's uh let's hear more calls that came
in for uh for our boy on the breast man
and I want to get that correction out
the gentleman's name is Jeff that called
in Jeff toy and Jeff is we're talking
about the breast breast e Jeff and I'm
sorry Jeff er you know saying your name
was Joey earlier I didn't know it man I
just was guessing and mom wasn't super
gay I'm not you know my nobody's been a
good guess or in my family let's hear
another call that came in for you though
Jeff well hey there mr. Kavon this is
Bethenny out here in Sacramento
California hey Bethenny I was just in
Bakersfield last night one of your semi
neighboring cities and had a great time
out there man I mean so many good people
you know there's so many good people out
in our in our country man and you know
and it was probably the the the fans
that came out were predominantly Mexican
and white that came through but just
great you know I wish I was drawing more
of a diverse audience I don't know if it
exists there that much I know that the
the area in Bakersfield is heavily
Mexican and white but it was just great
man it was awesome dude
I just felt so grateful let's hear more
and I'm calling in regard to the man
cities so you can either have that she
said at this time Jeff I didn't but
let's hear more did he use by being
overweight right which they're not
actual titties disrespect but then there
is a condition a hormonal medical
condition called gynecomastia I think
it's pronounced like that you got that
gynecomastia and I thought that was
something else there I thought that was
when uh you know a lady kind of I don't
want to say this kind of sit
on your facing you can't breathe that
good let's hear more where men have
actual breast tissue and we will mammary
gland not just that like you know it's
like a female breast right no oh yeah
that tit amount of exercise is going to
get rid of that if the medical condition
is hormonal maybe to see a doctor about
it if they're worried about it but I
mean maybe you just want to rock the
titties already nothing wrong with that
and that's what I'm saying is that like
I not think that that's what Jeff has
Jeff has them medical tits you know I'm
saying he could do a million workouts
you know I mean - you know you could put
him on a million workouts he might lose
70 pounds but he's still gonna have
these um these tits dude and you know
what are you gonna do then then you got
him he's almost disappeared he weighs 70
pounds he could barely lift his neck up
because he'd been running so long and
working out but he still got these
[ __ ] front bags and is that the biz
that the move I don't know if that's the
move you know but thank you for calling
that's that gynecomastia that he has and
so look that's a condition and then at
that point that's what I'm saying is
that's when I'm coming to Jeff and
saying hey look man if you got them and
you can't afford the surgery you know
you're not doing the surgery you don't
want to cut into your body you want to
rock that body you want to straight up
Justin Timberlake your life like the
Lord sets you out then what can you do
you [ __ ] put glitter on them you know
I'm saying put them you could
snickerdoodle him [ __ ] put them in
cinnamon and sugar and show them off at
the [ __ ] beach you know I mean
there's different things then you have
to embrace them and use them and that's
called onward let's hear more hey what's
up vo this is travis from austin texas
calling in
what's up travis you have a beautiful
city down there man homeward i hope
you're doing good man i'm just looking
forward every Monday to listening to
your show just wanted to tell you that
off the top thanks man you know it's
funny I get so no I guess it's weird
like some days I come in here I'm really
nervous in some days I'm just confused
and you know like this weekend I just
had a long weekend man like there's a
lot of like just career stuff is
happening right now and it's just
uh you know and honestly man I got in
and I was like haha you know I I did not
want to do it but I was just tired you
know just tired today and then um but
then I get any of these calls and stuff
and I go through the voicemails and I'm
like man you know I'm so lucky to like
be a part of like this little universe
you know and we're gonna do some really
cool stuff dude we just did this first
stand-up for single moms it's on YouTube
right now you can go watch it it was
Julie and this beautiful single mother
out in West Siloam Springs Oklahoma and
we're gonna do one for some different
cities you can go there and find out how
to submit a single mom that you know and
we took her out on the ten minutes she
had fun and we did a follow up call and
uh but check out that video man it was
really cool but we're gonna we're gonna
be doing some neat stuff and some I'm
thankful for you calling let's hear more
calling in response to Jeffrey man
there's no kind of casual way to say but
it's great man cuz you can you know what
you feel we're not making fun of him man
you feel that we're having fun with him
more I had that when I was younger too
man um and it was very pronounced oh
yeah man you got them pronoun sacks dude
and look I tell you man the first pair I
ever saw was on my boy and I used to
sleep over at his house man just to feel
my just to feel my body get [ __ ] a
rush and when I saw him bruh you know my
body gets all rushing and all the blood
runs to me run you know you know how I
get Oh word I caused a lot of
self-consciousness obviously you know
because I just didn't look the way he
was supposed to and she um man I
appreciate you sharing that dude that's
like Sherman brother they call him no
ties people call him nut Oz bruh or he
ever [ __ ] almond eyes you know if
they didn't want to say nut if they said
it too many times and it was kind of
losing esteem they call him almond eyes
you know or nutsack eyes more eventually
where I was calling me I eventually had
the surgery to remove that guy know
what the technical term is called and it
did a lot for me so I'm just encouraging
Jeffrey seems like he has a good
attitude but also I know for me that
surgery helped me to become kind of a
person that I was envisioned in my head
of level who I was I wanted to be and it
just you know it was just I thought it
was a great thing for me so maybe he
want to go that route because there's
really nothing you can do I was running
and exercising and doing a lot of
working out to try to get rid of it and
it just didn't it it's not something you
can get rid of through exercise so
anyway I hope this has been helpful man
love you do you need to come down to
Texas come down to Austin or even st. uh
me as possible
thanks man I will man thank you for
calling I appreciate that and no shade
back to our New Jersey guy look it's you
know sometimes people need to hear this
thing sometimes they need to hear this
thing and whoever knows what it is and
we don't know Jeff in person we don't
know Jeff tit in heart it man or
whatever you want to say we don't know
him so we don't know exactly what he has
but we feel like maybe he got says
gynecomastia you know I'm saying and
he's running around looks like somebody
uh you know tied a couple nut sacks to
the front of his sternum and so you know
at that point what do you do and all we
can do now is uh you know and and there
you have some information that if he
wants to get the surgery that had helped
this young man you know it helped him
feel better and that's Travis right
there or and it helped him feel better
and so that's one option you know Jeff
if you're out there I don't know what
that costs you know I'd say that we try
to pay for it here from this past
weekend but I don't know if we we
definitely don't I don't think have
money for a dang surgery dude but if you
end up getting into something like that
you know or something reach out to us
we'll be in touch man I'll reach out I
want to followup with you and and just
see what's going on dude I just have my
hand on my nuts for like a little while
and I forgot didn't even realize it and
almost just smelled it so you always
have to be on guard against your own
self that's crazy that you have to be on
guard against your own self
let's hear some other calls that came in
this is a follow up here we go hey you
know it's probably
from Ocala Flordia 1 the call in
reference to the 24 year old girl who
was struggling with depression a little
bit oh yeah she called in last week and
she talked about um when was a good time
and start taking antidepressants or what
experience I'd had with that let's hear
more Brian I have a two little pieces of
advice first one is really just talking
about it with somebody it usually kind
of eases my mind if I have somebody you
know that I love then let you know I
know loves me the second thing which you
know sometimes I like to smoke a smoke a
little bit of weed at night
because you know I get depression too
and whenever I smoke weed it kind of
erases it out of my mind man you know
what's so funny is you know is that that
I would do that I used to do that
sometimes and uh and my anxiety
sometimes would flare up but my
depression would go away I would not
feel depressed when I was on weed man
every movie was good even though I'd be
halfway through the movie have no
[ __ ] clue what was going on dude I
didn't know if it was Dances with Wolves
or King Kong I didn't have any idea but
it was good man
you know I didn't know if it was a
bridge to terabithia or if it was um
thank you for smoking you know I'm
saying I never knew I never had any idea
what was going on I didn't know if it
was even if it was Incredibles or if the
television didn't work you know I didn't
have any idea what was going on
sometimes on that weed but it did take
away my depression but for me with
anxiety it made it sometimes worse but
that is an option so there's two options
you got right there let's hear a little
more from from you Brian
here we go oh that's definitely
something that helps me I know and I
everyone smokes and neither one can
smoke but so she smokes or anything you
know that would be something I would
recommend anytime you start feeling like
that nope there you go thank you very
much for that let's get another follow
up suggestion here I think in the same
vein here to our depression caller from
last week onward okay a little I feel I
hope you can hear me all right this is
Brad calling from Maui ooh we got that
freaking pineapple bad boy huh we got
that freakin guava cat daddy out there
dude
you got one of them
you got that uh one of those sand castle
of Benedict Arnold's out there bro
somebody who's you know alleviated from
the states who's left us and moved out
there into the beautiful areas of Maui
beautiful if you've never been to Hawaii
you never been to Maui Kauai and you're
thinking about flying somewhere Spain or
damn Iceland or something go to why it's
great more sitting in bold those are all
day listening to you guys but this is
really important I just heard the girl
and you were talking about Zola and I
want to pass on that for a percentage of
people the SSRIs for me I was on it for
a few years and it turned me into a
raging alcoholic and I couldn't stop and
I lost everything because of it and it
took three years to figure out that it
was a Zoloft there's a book called
driven to drink and it's written by a
doctor about some antidepressants and it
was Olaf it did me wrong Wow so there
you go right there I appreciate you
calling there Brad I believe yeah and so
I guess you know you should be careful
and this is with any drug you know you
should be careful let's hear a little
more bread
I lost a multi-million dollar business
my family had temporary restraining
orders against me because I was just
frickin pissed off I could drink like 25
beers a day without slurring and walk
straight no hangover I heard you say
that you would drink gin it's a true
thing for a percentage of people and it
really needs to get out there
they put hundreds of you know make crap
your pants make you die all these things
they put as side effects that they never
put can cause heavy drinking or can
cause alcohol cravings yeah and there
you go and that's that right there yeah
and there you go there's a warning from
first first hand that's some time you
need it well no matter what drug you're
doing I don't care if you haven't
[ __ ] jelly beans okay read the label
because you know one out of seven
jillion people if they have the green
ones then they're gonna [ __ ] pull
their legs off their own body you know
are they're gonna hide cigarettes in
their [ __ ] or something
things have hot effects you need to know
what you're getting into before but some
of the side effects they might not tell
you about so you need to do your own
searches because think about this these
drug companies they probably only have
to tell you if a certain if um if those
you know say if they try a drug on on a
hundred people and in seven of those
people that have diarrhea's you know and
that's where poop is just trying to get
out of your body faster than usual
you got that [ __ ] Carl Lewis in your
ass you know and in so seven people then
they have to put it on the label as a
warning okay
could cause diarrhea but say if only two
people say if two people nope then they
don't have to put it on the label
there's probably like an FDA thing where
if it's a certain number of a hundred
people it affects it does that thing
then they have to put it on but there
might be six people out of a thousand it
makes them [ __ ] you know start
juggling or you know whistle when they
see their stepmother or something but as
long as that's not you know six out of a
hundred then they don't have to put it
on the label so sometimes you need to do
deeper searches because if they're all
running on requirements they're just
seeing how close it can get it can they
keep it just under enough people where
they have to label it as a warning and
there you go that gentleman right there
lost at all doings old often look I'll
tell you this dude I would drink a bunch
of gin on Zoloft
and I'd [ __ ] rocket masturbating and do
sex and did I could I could come out of
over a window sill I could do all kinds
of wild things and that was just part of
um part of my life at the time and that
was over in Charleston South Carolina I
used to live over there on King Street
and I had a good time over there and I
was sharing a room with a bunch of um
with some local people who were on the
sailing team and they were sailors and
that's people who you know they don't
want to swim but they still want to
[ __ ] be out on the water okay let's
get another Paul from New Hampshire I'm
just taking my lunch break and I wanted
to call and give some advice to the
rollerblader
thank you Paul from New Hampshire this
syrup country syrup and um winter coats
so you could be sticky and warm over
there and that's beautiful
more look bro keep there gonna make
funnier for nothing
you have no control so just have fun do
you doesn't matter
life's too short to not do what you like
doing no because I wasn't doing it for a
long time hmm and that's we had a
gentleman call in last week and he was a
rollerblader and he don't want to admit
it and I think it's you know I think
it's definitely taking the easy way out
a little bit because you should walk but
if you want to just wheel on over there
and show up you know like some kind of
[ __ ] damn wizard then that's your
thing
but like he's saying if you like to do
something you go ahead and do it man I
like to scrapbook do you know I'm saying
I used to be that bad boy with the
glitter and the glue guns son and you
think all that's lame that's gay that's
this that's that that's soft you know
but guess what you know how many bad men
just wanted to come over and see daddy
work that and glitter stick work that
glue stick work that break and yarn ball
let's hear more you know you're [ __ ] all
right a scooter
with a motor not on those fruitcake
grandchild ones you know people don't
like it but they usually keep it to
themselves that's true man yeah you wear
a scooter with a motor on it there's a
little board that's a little more friend
I still kind of French but Brennan shop
does that one with no motor man can you
imagine seeing big Brendan Schaub
pushing his heavy ass down the street
you know what I'm saying all hopped up
on bee stings he's got honey hanging off
his ass cheeks and he's just heavy
legging just heavy legging down the
street on my scooter and that's big
Brendan Schaub out there
[Music]
on their scooter but look we make fun um
but at the same time and if that makes
him happy then scoot scoop big be easy
scoop scooped thank you for calling
let's hear we had a couple of calls that
came in let's get into one right here
hey what's up do I'm Rodrigo I'm also a
mailman like I got it called in earlier
last week and actually he's a mailman
thank you for calling him Rodrigo that
mailman and we had another mailman
calling last week a lot of people out
there you know getting postal out there
in the world and I appreciate it and
also what's amazing is I I can hear dogs
in the background man that's so perfect
thank you for calling Rodrigo a little
pickle here I deliver out in Las Vegas
[ __ ] blazing heat and delivering the
wrist part town and last week an older
woman confronted me I wanted to uh we'll
start off the have sex with me in
exchange for money he go suddenly your
name is goes from Rodrigo to you that
FedEx boy they trying to get you to
package it up and she's very wealthy and
I don't really know how to feel about
that I wanted it hopefully maybe you
could use some advice
I don't really know what to tell my
girlfriend or my parents or you know
like I don't know what they would think
of me well here's what I would do I want
to say will you think of yourself what
would you think yourself if you do it
you know do you need some excitement in
your life you know is it's not a love
thing so is it I mean if your wife found
out you know like what what kind of
relationship do you guys if you told
your wife look some lady she want to
drop me couple you know with Jeezy you
gotta don't [ __ ] for less than 700 you
know she won't you know drop me a GZ to
get out there you know
I mean maybe your wife might be
supportive mighty spice up y'all's
relationship maybe you talk to them
about it take a family vote have them
all vote blindly like they do on Big
Brother
atención house guess Rodrigo might [ __ ]
and see what they think you know have
everybody put their two cents in make it
a fun family thing if you think if
you're worried about hiding it then
you're opening up to everybody and
they're not gonna judge you may you're
out there doing good work you know what
I'm saying man it's like you're out
there doing good work doing mail and so
let's see what they want or if it's your
own thing you're keeping it to yourself
you want to do some little secret to
spice up your universe spice up your
universe man you know I used to watch
them I used to be afraid to tell people
that I watched the movie with Meryl
Streep's in it in the movie the movie
with Meryl was um bridges of arm of I of
Madison County and it's about a lady she
has a good life but one weekend she gets
that hoorah in her you know I'm saying
she gets some wild photographer [ __ ] and
she takes some hits off that [ __ ] off
of that Kodak man's baby bird you know
and it's exciting and it's a you know
she never goes to you know any fancy
countries or doesn't he amazing you know
not amazing she said I'm she's a mother
you know and that's the most powerful
thing you can be in the world I mean you
basically your uterus is the dam you
know that's the Wizard of Oz right there
I don't think we're in Kansas anymore
you know that's the most powerful
instrument in the world people talking
about um you know the new operating
system Ain iOS ain't got nothing on that
V AG and so you know and so she she just
had to have that weekend Meryl Streep's
had to have that weekend or she just
found some pleasure where she did
something just to have her own little
she needed you know she had a her life
was filled with stars but she needed a
you know I'm saying she needed a [ __ ]
put a something special sparkly that was
just for her out there in the world she
had to just point that she had to plan
her own little North Star up there you
know she had on
to Orion's belt a little you know and
sometimes you have to do that for you so
you decide man that's your decision if
you open it up to the family then that's
their decision but you decide for you
man you know you decide onward man thank
you for calling in and good luck out
there man if y'all [ __ ] out there and
doing mail and look if I walked in on a
mailman [ __ ] more power to them if
dogs are chasing you all day it's your
job you should be able to [ __ ] a little
think about that cuz this man out there
got dogs after him imagine if you work
at Charles Schwab or CBS Studios or you
know wherever else and Nabisco or
something you are CEO or Wall Street
imagine trying to get your day trade and
done when you got a [ __ ] Doberman
after you ass I'm saying some people
have a rougher Amen brother thank you
for calling in hitting the hotline let's
take another call here here we go hi
dear this is Bridget from Canada and I
just had a question with regards to
celebrity's DNA oh thank you for calling
Bridget celebrities gaming it's very
interesting let's hear about your
question I recently got a celebrity a
known stand-up comedian not you of
course that DM me and wanted some dirty
pictures and to chat more and exchanged
numbers I do think he's attractive but I
don't know if I should get back to him
or not I'd like to know your thoughts
let me know thanks oh wow thank you for
calling Bridget so you had that you had
a comedian reach out to you and he was
talking about the dirty pictures man I
hope I want to say that this wasn't me
and this is and you know this wasn't me
but I just you know parties always
scared but anyhow thank you for calling
Bridget what do you do I think you know
here's what I think about dirty pictures
I mean if you're I don't ever include
your face in a dirty picture if a guy's
for you for a dirty picture or a girl
ask you for a dirty picture don't
include your face it's not up me that's
not I mean they they look they want you
but at that time there
heat in on crops you know I'm saying
they're not thinking photography -
thinking crotchet ography you know
you're thinking Christ ography and they
want to see that theater they want to
see that nipple you know or if it's our
boy Jeff toy they want to see them
freaking straight up you know their
milky nut sacs you know they want to see
it all so that's it don't include your
face no matter what you do and then
after that it's up to you you wanna have
some fun on your phone and send out a
picture of some Wasi don't do your thing
girl but just take pride in whatever you
do if you can I mean I suggest meet him
in person showing that thing from a
couple feet away you know I don't know
how healthy it is just because when you
start just getting mad and that's what
you want then it gets a little squirrely
I think if you're the guy who's asking
for that Oh send that because then I'm
not thinking about you at all I'm just
thinking about this thing and that's uh
it's natural but is it healthy that's
only you know but if it's a comedian I
wonder who it is - of course I wonder
who it is I mean is is only like about
nine decent looking comedians so onward
and let's hear let's hear another call
that came in here we go hey Ron this is
California and I'm calling to see your
collection of the five people you're
closest to and usually my five closest
people I kind of push away because kind
of don't want to be around and that type
of lifestyle anymore okay if you're a
reflection of your five closest people
and you recently pushed those people
away because you want to be in that
lifestyle anymore okay more I just want
to know your thoughts and then you guys
you might have for finding new people to
empower yourself and finding like-minded
people if you ever had to put yourself
in a position
yeah well you show thank you so much man
thank you for the call um you know when
you have to get into a new place and you
have to find new people to spend time
with I mean for me um you know moving
has always done that when you move to a
new place you end up necessity creates
things for me like I know if I don't
keep a certain level of struggle in my
life then I will not I won't work as
hard I know that if I you know if I if I
make things too easy then I don't shine
in I don't shine I don't work hard I
don't try when I don't have a certain
level of uncomfort when I don't have a
certain level of struggle and and I know
you're wondering well how does this work
into what I'm talking about well you
know sometimes you have to put yourself
into like a new situation can cause that
that's what I'm saying
so if maybe if you move yourself into
like Geographic you do a geographic you
actually move to a new place what else
churches something you know people
wanted to you know bag on religion or
whatever whatever dude yeah as long as
you're not there fighting wars against
another country because you think your
religion is better than theirs that's
really the shitty part but if you're
just Church to meet people get to know
people feels to feel a connection to a
higher power and that can be any
denomination you want man you can be you
know Allah Yiddish [ __ ] crystal ball
Jesus Christ whatever whoever you want
to find whatever bad boy out in the sky
you want to find her bad baby out in the
sky you want to find go get her mother
nature bro you know I'm saying if you
want to be christened by that by that
big of a job that big you know mother
nature that big sky vagina whatever you
want to believe in like the Native
Americans whatever you want to believe
in but a higher power can become that
for you you also don't have to have that
you could believe in witchcraft okay you
could go for that but church sports some
type of a sports and that sport can be
Dungeons and Dragons okay okay that
sport can be anything for me well change
some of my circle of friends and humans
was a 12-step program and I'm not trying
to push you towards alcoholics and
or push you towards a 12-step program of
any sort but my problems I choose to not
do drugs and alcohol I don't know if I'm
an addict sometimes but I do know that
the benefits of that program the friends
I've met the way that I think about
myself now and the environments that I'm
in now constantly because of that
program I know that those are worth
giving up the drugs and alcohol so it's
for me that's like a ticket to the show
okay what is that what is the ticket
price the ticket price is drugs and
alcohol I don't use them that's how
that's my payment okay you can have
those you can have that ticket price now
the show is I get new friends more
self-esteem I get processes to help me
work out my problems I know you're not
asking for all that you're just asking
if I let go of this group of friends how
do I find a new group but I'm telling
you fast action ways that can help what
else
yoga get in a [ __ ] [ __ ] get in at
eight now here's a small thing you can
do you can get into it start a text
chain with some other people you know
around town you know start back with
your family work on those relationships
if you can and also get outdoors don't
stay indoors you know uh darkness is
darkness man and we say we know we we we
hypothesize it a lot but darkness is
darkness if you're in the dark you're in
the dark so get outdoors you know find
the Sun you know there's a do some
volunteer work man volunteer work
helping somebody else you will be so
amazed how quickly new path you're shown
and how many amazing people you'll meet
those are just some thoughts man but
I'll give you a call and give you a buzz
this week and check in with you as well
you know you got me bruh you know so you
still got one left up let's hear a
little bit more man
let's get another call right here here
we go
hey what's up my name is Danny I'm
calling from Miami Beach over here in
Florida I Danny down in Miami Miami
Danny Miami Danny I really just wanted
to leave a little story with you wanted
to get some of your advice on this I
have a co-worker I'm 21 years old start
off this are you 21
huh he's 21 how's it going lovely lady
co-worker of mine she's about 3334
it is Miami so she got some serious work
done good not oh she got that work huh
she got that facial construction bra
sometimes women get all kind of [ __ ]
dude so you know some lady will forget
her freakin you know some look somebody
to get their pose it put on their neck
and suddenly they got that uh they got
that neck Rotch you know and you're like
dang boy and they wear a scarf and next
thing you know they take that scarf off
and next thing you know y'all are [ __ ]
so you can get all you can get all kind
of stuff replaced and removed in
everything let's hear more not a
bad-looking human at all she recently
asked me at work for my hand in her meds
this lady proposed to me she's one of
these Europeans over here from Miami
Yugoslavian or you Canadian or one of
those things I don't know yeah bruh
Slavs cranes you know what I'm saying
one of them Slavs cranes um yeah so she
asked for your hand in marriage he's
older she probably has money I'm
guessing this is Miami anyway
her main source of income other than
work she gets a little freaky with these
NBA players baseball players who come
down here okay so she's an escort and
she wants and why does she want you I
know she has the money to get into this
marital situation for her papers I don't
know how to feel about the whole thing I
feel kind of pushed into it I don't know
I'm gonna have to consummate this
marriage with this rather freaky
European lady who is maybe my same
height and is used to be giant just let
me know what you do oh you got a lot of
things so she's used to dealing with
giant she's just you're dealing with the
athletes gladiators you know I'm talking
about real gladiators you know she's
used to really dealing with those guys
so you gonna come in you can
that third-string [ __ ] you know I'm
saying you're gonna be that third-string
[ __ ] you know I mean you that bench dick
you ain't that starting lineup if she's
hooking up with real athletes because
she's making real money out there she's
out there Skorton and there's no shame
in that
you know if women if that's how she
makes her money that's how she that's
that's how she makes her money so look
man she wants to be there for the papers
here's what I would do if you want to
marry somebody for the papers now first
of all you're bringing somebody into the
country I mean this [ __ ] what you're
doing is illegal you got to know that I
mean you know I mean at least you're not
you know but if you're gonna bring
somebody into the country man I go I go
30,000 brah and a couple years of
marriage that's what I do I do thirty
thousand couple years of marriage and
you get signed jerseys of everybody she
banks so then that way like everybody at
least you get something out of it so
years later when she's gone and it's all
separated everything at least you
running around with that autograph Tony
Gwynn you know at least you running
around with that autographed Davante
Adams go pack go you know there you go
so that that now we're talking now we're
talking right there and that's teamwork
but dude look man if you in the
import-export business you import and
export and wives maybe you'd that funny
husband maybe this is just something you
start next thing you know a year from
now you marry him you know you know you
marrying a nine-year-old who's trying to
get into America for a million you know
I'm saying and that's that American
dream right there it's you know is that
evolving learning and evolving man thank
you for calling in very much Danny on
that on that fake marriage thank you for
calling let's take one more call here
man we're gonna wrap it up today I
appreciate you guys so much for your
calls here we go
beer man at detective hey Jack thank you
for calling
homeward everybody's called just just
been doing with a lot of internals right
I'm sorry to hear
that dude I feel you man you know I'll
be honest I've had kind of a good week
and so I almost feel ashamed saying that
to you when you're calling you're not
feeling that super more they're dealing
with the loss of a loved one a
grandfather Loras lived with him for 30
years young man and he raised me I lost
in this past December and I lost my girl
in January and things been kind of funny
ever since obviously well you know been
been dabbling into them Dark Arts if you
know what I mean and you know finding
fun some of that Devils dangerous and
you know just just trying to get by it
seems like I get high I get low so I get
high again and you know man I just want
to say thank you um I've listened to you
for a little while now and uh yeah you
made me realize you know sometimes it
comes down to it you just got to depend
on yourself there's not much else you
know there's not much else to it you got
to be hard and and I just wanted to say
thanks man I appreciate you thanks man
uh I appreciate you man I appreciate you
jack I appreciate that call you know
when you said that um and it's a hard
realization is it and I'm sorry if
you're lost it I'm sorry you know I bet
your grandfather really loved you you
know it's selling if you got to spend
now much time with somebody and senior
citizens man there's such treasure boxes
you know we don't look at it like that
sometimes especially in America we don't
value especially in especially really in
America
I mean it's and real American culture
like you know a lot of cultures people
value their their grandparents a lot
more um but it's uh you know that loss
you know I'm so sorry if your loss and
your girl you know I can't even imagine
that but man that's got it man that's a
you know that is such a hard
and real moment and well how scary that
is to realize that you have to rely on
yourself man and that is such a lonely
real adult moment you know and it's so
powerful when that kind of thing happens
I've had some moments like this happen
and it's so powerful because you you
know you only feel it like when it when
it happen you know when you the feeling
is kind of something momentary but it's
you know it's uh it's the actual feeling
of that realizing that you are response
you that really it's just you like you
have these other people you love and you
have these people you care about a
memory but in the end you know
especially as I'm sure you really like
when they leave and they leave this
earth they leave your life and it's just
you and you are responsible for holding
yourself up no matter what and man that
is a little that's a beautiful but
extremely lonely and powerful moment but
I've found I've seen that you can kind
of go to ways from there and you can you
know you know we use stuff like cocaine
and we use stuff like drugs especially
offers to make us feel and I used to use
cocaine to make me feel man I wanted to
feel so bad my whole life I just never
felt anything I had ton of amazing
moments and experiences and I've been
excited and I've been low and I've been
happy and sad but I never I was such a
Kay I was such a [ __ ] box I was such a
box that I wasn't I wasn't a cage a cage
things can get in and out of you can be
cagey and you can let still let things
in and out of a cage door space between
the bars there's a sieve there's a give
and a take
but when you're a box when you are a
[ __ ] cube you don't know what's in
there
everything you're working out here man
and and then and then finally and so I
would use drugs to just simulate
anything inside it just to simulate
something real and so I understand you
know understand using that to get high
to feel something and I hope that you
can you know I wish I knew some
suggestions man I just you know I love
you brah you know dude and I'll you know
I don't want you to feel alone you know
it makes me sad to think that you know I
don't want you to think that the world
is just gonna take everybody from you
and that you're not going to have people
that care about you or that more people
aren't gonna come into your life that
want you and I want to show you that
they love you you know you know I don't
want you to feel like you're not worth
you're not worth finding joy outside of
drugs and outside of alcohol you know I
don't want you to be afraid to be a cage
you know I don't want you to turn into a
box man but just don't be you know I
don't know oh man I just don't want you
to feel alone bro you know that's tough
man it's just
but you can you know I think you're so
you're at least you're aware so you're
calling you're talking about this leash
or where and you can choose to surround
yourself or you're gonna have to make
some efforts to not be alone and to not
give in to the dark side of [ __ ]
because that's gonna be the easy side
I'll buy this gram you know I'll cop
this escort I'll do this I'll do that
I'll find my way into the dark arts I'll
stay inside today you know I'll just put
another thing on the on the episode
recorder button on the TV and I'll watch
another series but to get out to venture
to stay open it's gonna take some
vulnerability you're gonna have to show
up at places even when you don't want to
because all you really want to do is
show people how much you're hurting but
the vulnerability there is not hey look
how much I hurt the vulnerability is to
turn and say look how strong I am
because the herd is gonna be there no
matter what and people that love you and
people that care and people that come
along
they'll recognize it man and they'll see
it and they'll help you repair it and I
believe that I believe that a hundred
percent all right guys I want to thank
you guys for uh hitting the hotline and
if you have any thoughts or questions or
responses to anybody that we've called
about we're gonna do some follow-up
calls with some of these people I'm
gonna let you guys know that Ridge
wallet has sponsored trick lung Mickey
and he's that bet he's that baby cat who
got them new air bags from somebody that
died um you know they had a crack addict
that died and he got a lung transplant
and Mickey got his air bags he got them
new he got them new dust duffels you
know he got them new hitters so but
ridge wallet is sponsored that uh we're
gonna take Mickey skydiving whenever his
lungs can handle it because lungs can't
handle everything but we're gonna do it
soon for him all right guys I just want
to say thank you guys so much for your
calls if you have any responses
follow-ups questions anything you can
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three if you have
friends in China and Shanghai let them
know I'll be over there if you have
friends in any of those other cities let
them know I'm coming you know send some
people out let's make something special
happen you know thank you guys for uh
for being a part of this past weekend I
want to thank our this past weekend ders
Facebook group I'll jump on there this
weekend in um and do a live video or
something on there that's just for them
or put a video up or something I want to
thank our patreon errs you know they do
so much and that's allowing us to carry
out our stand-up for single moms at
these different cities I want to thank
all of our listeners just for being just
for being around look we're just
experiment we don't really know what
we're doing and when I say we I mean
myself producers Nick Davis Chris Perez
Gianni Paolo and and just everybody our
sponsors everybody this has been a neat
and neat experiment and I feel like
we're just still getting started so be
good to yourselves out there you know
because you probably deserve it even
sometimes when we think we don't you
know the craziest thing we can do is
love ourselves it's crazy you know it's
so crazy that how hard it is to really
really do that you know and I'm not
coming from a place that I say I know I
don't know but I want to learn you know
I want to learn that's for sure
alright I'll see you guys in Wyoming
Illinois at the Paramount Theatre this
Friday night the second show was sold
out we still have the tickets on the
early show that 6 p.m. on a Friday is
the Early Show and then I'll see you
guys in Oxnard California at levity live
July 6th 7th and 8th guys it's
summertime and it's life and this is it
and you can do it so don't give up on
yourselves we need each other
[Music]
celebrate
you gotta celebrate a tall man we have
to try it you know come on we can we got
this it's never too late baby we got
[Music]
we celebrate
Oh
[Music]
we die
celebrate guys
[Music]